One category of validation rules are requirement requirements placed
by the value on one dimension on the values of another dimension. For example,
if you've got event connectors that require delivery notification, then you
also need to be concerned with the cardinality rules, synchronization rules, and
mode rules. Might be situations where it's not a strict rule, but
it's some kind of caution. Certain combinations may be unstable or unreliable.
That is they're dynamic, the dynamics of that particular situation may not work
in all circumstances having to do with concurrency and locality. There
may be restrictions. 'Kay, certain combinations may be invalid, for example,
passing by name and transient can't be used together. And there might be
prohibitions. Total incompatibility of dimensions, such as streams and atomicity